[Music]
welcome back to the corridor cast
um we're trying something different
today uh we
have played many a game of spy fall
in uh in the life of node and in
corridor
but uh we've never done it on the
quarter cast so
um this little game that we have here is
um
well it's a simple little game but
basically the game gives you
clues clues as to um
what location uh something is happening
in well
hold on let me i'll explain the rules
hold on the game doesn't actually give
you clues
sorry for interrupting jake but for
clarity yeah i'll explain the rules
basically that's spy fall excellent game
what we're gonna do is we are all going
to be secret members
at a location and one of them one of the
people here is going to be a spy
we everyone except one person will know
the location
that we are in and the spy you'll not
know the location we're in
and so from there the game progresses
by each of us asking each other
questions about this location in an
attempt
to figure out who is the spy and who's
not obviously the spy
will have no idea what we're talking
about and
we'll have to ask a question hoping that
it sounds like they know the location
the the key here is is if you're not the
spy
you don't want to give away or reveal
the location so the questions we ask
each other
have to be veiled and secretive and
you know i guess you know everything
here is done with a little
tongue-in-cheek here you know we're
trying to
say we work at a grocery store but not
reveal that to the spy
so uh a game of wits
it's it's one of the best games it's
definitely one of the best games it's a
great line game
like uh you got to be you want to be
for hours like at disney world um it's
perfect
for that so you got to be clever
um you don't want to if you're not the
spy you obviously do not want to give
away the location
as in obviously stating a question that
anybody could pick up and understand as
as the location because obviously then
the spy is gonna
win and then with the spy can win by
declaring
the location and getting it right and
the non-spies can win
by identifying the spy yes and ousting
them
correct yes so we'll take if if at
any point someone thinks there's a spy
just say i'm calling a vote
i think jake's the spot but if you do
that and then
everyone raises their hands and the vote
only succeeds
if it's a majority and it fails
if it it's if it's not so in this case
however two people
this spy can out himself by just saying
the location they just go i know where
we are and everyone's like cool
they only got one shot at it they say
one location and if they're right they
win
but if they say that then obviously and
they and they're wrong then obviously
you know who the spy is and they lost
hopefully we don't vote each other off
the island let's see how this game
progresses it's very intense yeah and if
you vote somebody off
and it's not the spy the game keeps
going no no no no the spy totally wins
oh they do yeah if if you i've played it
both ways
okay i think it's better it's just cuts
it cuts it off right there
starts over the spy wins and then
everyone's like oh we failed we voted
for our our teammate that's so sad all
right
let's start game i've played this like
all right let's get you guys
so we're playing on
spyfall.tannercrewson.com
so basically we'll see a timer here and
we say whether we
are or aren't the spy at the top
now one
person uh jake you see how you have
first next your name jake
that means yes it's you will ask the
first question you asked
and no backsies okay you can't double
back with the question you have to pass
it to someone else
all right jake it's up to you to begin
the game hopefully your camera
feed of us is very sharp because you're
gonna have to read every minute can you
see our facial expressions
can you see all of our faces yeah i can
see all of your faces
okay and you all look like spies to me
this is gonna be
a very short game
um all right uh first question
um sam
yes do you need money
to enter this place do i need money to
enter this place
no you do not need money to enter this
place
jordan you're running on the hot seat
have you played this before no
okay i'll pick it up um
i just watched a node video of you guys
okay ten minutes ago perfect
okay all right here's a question um
is this the type of place
uh if you don't work here that is
if if you go to this location and you
don't
work here are you going to stay here for
a short amount of time or a long amount
of time
i'd i'd probably just stay as long as
i'm needed
okay
that's interesting all right as long as
you don't but you don't
work there huh
interesting wait is jake question take
the spy
that was a very spy kind of look at him
to glance again he looks like he's
trying to figure out the location
all right interesting so all right so
now jordan gets asked a question right
okay all right that's fine i believe you
jake
do you promise jordan it's your turn to
ask anyone except pretty please
nick yes
what do you think you would like go here
for
i mean i'd go here to just clock in at
my job you know
um involves
conversating with a variety of people
would you agree i would agree fellow not
spy
so jordan
um
oh i can't pass it right back okay okay
yeah you can't yeah you can't pass it
right back so jake
is this somewhere you would you know if
you went here do you think you'd call
your parents to like give you a ride
home
no no okay you would not
yeah i think that's a great answer
yeah very very uh elaborate yeah
uh well you asked me did you not ask me
a yes or no question
just there i'm sorry i don't want to
give away too much
no of course not you definitely don't he
is a lawyer he is a lawyer you don't
want to give away too much
yeah all right um sam um
shoot
your friends are often at this location
is that is that a statement that i'm
supposed to agree or disagree with
no no no in your experience
your personal experience are your
friends
at this location oh yeah all of my
are at this location
oh yeah oh yeah all of them
i i mean it's crazy how many of my
friends
are here and i'm usually at home feeling
left out
right so yeah okay
um so here's the point the turning point
for me in the game where i'm like all
right
who is the spy who do we think is the
spy and who do we don't think this is by
because nick i know
you're not the spy i have a feeling why
would you think that why would i think
that
i have a feeling i look i gotta ground
myself in some decision
sure sure i think jordan's might not be
the spy
but i think jake could be the spy too
i you see i'm not sure if jordan's
shaking her head right now yes because
she wants to divert attention away from
jake but you too
are clearly in my in my i i spy
two spies right i spy is very
a very obvious spy and it is not i
said the not spy okay oh
well well um
then i guess uh why don't you ask jordan
why don't you ask jordan a question
i'll ask a question let's get to the
bottom of this let's get to the bottom
of this
um i would have to say
[Music]
um okay
i'm going to put a
oh gosh these are the hardest questions
okay um
usually we cut this dead air out yeah
no that's that's why i wanted to do it
on the podcast because it
gives people a chance to think about it
also christian and i
are we going to add in the location
reference for people
so that they can also follow along and
and and like you know know
the location okay okay
this is like your eight-minute cruise
ship question to d yes back in the day
eight minute question i know um i'm
gonna screen cap
each one so that you can
cool oh so jakes
so jordan um would you
say i'm going to screencap each location
that we're
at so that he can know yes and if you're
the spy obviously you'll have to
ask us what those locations are
afterwards
well i know what i know what location it
is sam because i'm the spy
and you're on the ocean liner
did i win this took a turn no did i win
no did i ask ah
i told you you dirty
no no it's the police station police
station son
there's the police station y'all your
friends are there
well that's that's what i said like that
to your question because i knew you i
felt like you were the spy so i was like
yeah i thought you were like a police
officer or something working at the
police station all your friends
didn't hear me he was like i'll ask you
a question shoot i thought we were
talking about
i thought we were talking about an ocean
liner and that's why i said you
specifically because your bachelor party
was on an ocean
i know it was a great bachelor party on
a cruise ship i see
it was it was wonderful um the other
thing that's not helping is uh
your guys's camera feed froze so i can
see
nothing except for gasp except for me
yeah oh
christian has the feed going oh copy so
i can see you yeah
okay i'll just mimic everyone else's
expressions
um
[Music]
yeah i think you might be at a slight
disadvantage here jake but i think we'll
uh we'll roll with it
all right we'll see a new one hopefully
you don't become the spy again
and the round yes i'm sure it happened
oh someone exited
okay so just so i'm clear when you're
when you are not the spy
it doesn't give you the location
reference document does it no you just
get the one
it tells you where you are and then
shows you all the other ones too gives
you a job title in the location
okay so it does show you all the other
ones yeah so in case you want to like
pivot and like fib a little bit right
okay so that's what i
i couldn't remember if it showed you all
the other ones or not and so i was
trying to cover
let's just say like when i screen capped
this
it really i know that that kind of gave
it away
what are you screen capping
uh i just want to make sure i'm
capturing desktop correctly
we're doing this all live that's that's
all we know we're doing all
right at the end of the round we reveal
it anyway so i'll know
[Music]
scroll down to the bottom or refresh it
maybe and discord
yeah because i closed that room you
shouldn't be
i'll just go backwards uh let me just
disconnect and reconnect yeah
one second leave game
leave game what's the access code again
uh c g
k and i'm back okay
we're good to go all right round two
here we go
everyone's jumping yeah
now if you don't know what's happening
yet that's totally normal
um but uh the more rounds you play
the funner it gets i'm just going to
read it mine says waiting for players
too oh here we go there you go
something's running
if it's blank you should just refresh it
cool
still not seeing jordan no oh there you
are
all right here we go hot drop three
dropping jc all right beginning here we
go
all right all right everyone have the
rolls
nick's yeah going to kick it off
hmm well nick yeah so
i see you here yeah yeah really great
seeing everyone here
yeah yeah really great really great to
be
here we should be here more often yeah
yeah so
sam did uh did uh
were you really excited to come to this
location
today are you here on your own volition
not
well sorry which one which question
sorry sorry
number two number two am i here on my
own volition yes
yes yes okay yes i mean
you you're not required by law to be
here
so it's not the police station yeah
exactly jake okay okay well unless
you're
a police officer or somebody who works
there all right which case it's still
i think that rules out the world war ii
squad too
yeah if it's if it's russian anyway yeah
yeah
all right jordan sam
jordan jordan yes level with me
i'm sorry um
are you here for work or for pleasure
i'm definitely here to get some work
done all right you got it
yeah um so all right
uh jake really yeah yeah yeah really
hmm yeah interesting answer
already getting suspicious it's a very
interesting answer
very interesting yeah yeah might i say
very i don't know about that yeah i mean
yeah i can see it yeah
i can see it yeah my life
yeah cake all right jordan
hi like how question up
how how long would you say your stay
today would be
today just today today
anywhere from eight to
nine hours
eight to nine hours that's that's that's
that is
quite exciting that's a yeah full last
day
you're really punching in the clock
aren't you jake i'm
[Laughter]
uh okay um
i wasn't super convinced with sam's
question or nick's question um
especially sam's question
the the ambiguity of it so i'm going to
amber
of it dare i say it's the perfect
question
no dary you can dare say it but i'll
dare say it was not
all right sam
give me the perfect question um
i know you got a few in there
[Laughter]
sam um yes do you
do you find yourself here on a saturday
afternoon
i mean
i i'm not really in control
of when
this is so i'll be there when i need to
okay all right all right yeah i'm
satisfied i don't think sam's the spy
thanks jake now nick
yes you're welcome i don't i don't think
you're the spy
again i think i was
either sitting right there or it's jake
but jake i agree we're in the same
position here he has an air of
confidence
about about him this time that he didn't
have on the previous round
which is why i asked jordan another
question
this it's more important when you're
playing this game to focus on what
you're doing
when you are not the spy not saying that
i am
not the spy but the shaking sweating etc
you want to like and like not do that
you got to play like you are not the spy
no matter what
yeah yes it's interesting you say that
now jake so
last time i asked you a question jordan
you said i asked if you were here for
work or pleasure and you said you're
here for work
um i guess my
uh question is uh
uh what are you working on here
why is that funny that's a very specific
question
yeah it's almost too specific
considering there's a range of what i
could possibly be doing
yeah but i mean you have a role don't
you
maybe you'd reference that if you want
or
[Laughter]
but if i if i reference that it gives a
little too much
okay i mean just get something there's a
range just give us like a little behind
the scenes look at to
what you're yeah just uh i get [ __ ] done
all right kind of like a top dog
okay well i am looking at my
role and it says i'm i'm the top dog so
i don't know if they're suit top dogs
because i'm not the spy
this is my role it doesn't say top dog
but it's
very close to that you have no idea what
my role could possibly be i know but
that's why i asked
jordan jordan if you're not the spy
i'm going to recommend that you ask nick
one more question
just so we can just so we can vet this
come on let's clear
okay on everything that is holy yes
do you enjoy your job i do it really
depends on
when i'm doing it but usually i find it
very
very favorable yeah it also depends on
you know
who i'm who i get to be around
interesting so very interesting
i'm just going to raise my hand here you
know let's take a vote let's let's take
a vote sam who do you propose
uh jordan
i second this all right we're all voting
for this are you the spy
i am the spot of course
i have no idea what i was doing the
whole time
where are
[Music]
was it the submarine no it was a
corporate party
it's a corporate party which is why
whether here
you're here for work a pleasure but
i will say that that wasn't a total
giveaway because
i i'm an entertainer so i was there for
work technically i'm an owner
owner of the party yeah you're the owner
of the corporate party the corporation
yeah i was the accountant oh wow
so i mean yeah technically i was there
for work too that was
like you're entertained yeah i don't
know how i could top the owner
yeah you straight up told the boss that
you were
of a movie that's like straight out of a
movie when somebody's trying to fake it
and then somebody unexpectedly
i was so scared well it's like
yeah yeah yeah you could get away with
that in a movie though
yeah i was pretty embarrassed yeah
all right sure now we're getting one
back i feel like we're starting the game
yeah we're starting the game we got a
new location we got new goals
leave games
oh nope you're right so
so i find that if you are the spy the
easiest thing you can do
is to pick the location you think it is
obviously but then more specifically
give yourself a roll because without
that role it's hard to play
the game i think i mean i think you just
go 100 confident
but yeah uh so on that note i'm asking
the first question jake coming in hot
all right hamburger
or hot dog
uh should i propose that you're the spy
right now sam or
no no no answer my question hamburger
or hot dog
this is based on the location okay
um i look at the location think about my
location i see your location and i raise
you
a it's a stretch but
i'll go for it and i'm gonna say hot dog
oh yeah hot dog
hot dog correct answer all right
um
[Music]
jordan yes um
is this location breezy or stuffy
there's definitely a slight breeze
feels nice in my hair
all right yeah definitely keyword
confidence
absolutely absolutely
100 definitely
a thousand
what would you wear here
um probably some loose fitting clothes
something comfortable
yeah you know something
don't have to think about it too much
you sure yeah okay
okay yeah
all right sam what's up
sandals or boots
okay interesting
[Music]
uh well jake coming back
at you all right
all right buddy are we talking
um
are we talking surf and turf
or are we talking meatballs
these choices
[Laughter]
i don't know man um
i kind of think sam is the spy
m if you are not the spy jack i suggest
you look at your location
i'm not stalling i'm just pointing out
that sam has given me
a rep of repetition in his form
of questioning answer the question
we all prior to this time to know your
answer answer the question
so it was what for meatballs surf and
turf
i can't answer this question because if
i answer it correctly it's too much of a
giveaway
well then answer it incorrectly or don't
tell us
how do i answer this meatballs or surf
and dry
um think very hard about this
i'll say this oh god okay
just just say the wrong answer
sarcastically
it it depends on the night
depends on the night depends oh my gosh
depends on the night
hell yeah i'll say that all right
because i think cause i think sam is the
spy and i can't give him any more
information
hold on i we're dealing with two
conflicting
opinions from you jake either my
question reveals the location
therefore uh i guess
i guess exonerating me or my question is
so
out there that i'm the spy and i need to
figure out which one it is
you know you know what it is okay listen
it's my turn to ask the questions i'll
be answering i'll be asking the
questions
thank you very much um jordan
yeah hello um man um
i'm trying to think i i really don't
want to give the answer away here this
is tricky because we've already given
away a lot of information
have we i think so we
didn't even answer the last one loose
fitting clothes
hot dogs
[Laughter]
it's you know there's air
it's all spilled out it all makes sense
okay this one this one's a little bit
this one's a little bit more ambiguous
given the locations we have
available here but i'm gonna get a
little bit more specific okay
okay
do you stay here and is it not your home
listen
if i wanted to stay i could
but i do have a home and i could stay
there too
yeah right i mean that's true uh
voting for jake as the spy sam is
definitely the spy
he is voting for me we all know do you
remember
we all voted are you guys serious you're
really voting all for me
yeah yep i am not the spy
oh it is oh no
oh no cause it's sam
oh no it's because it's totally safe it
was me
i knew it i felt it oh no i forgot to
ask him this
question was so dumb the sleeper
what was your
well at first i was like imagining it
was beach um
because the hot dog can we tell them
yeah okay what was it
ocean liner ocean lighter really okay
sorry
why are you spitting clothes totally
making sense for that our feud
turned into vengeance and i voted for
you look what you've done sam
what i did you were blinded to the spy
right in front of your eyes
you know what next round i'm going to
cool my jets a little bit
i'm going to take a back seat in this
next round
hopefully could you hopefully i'm not
the spy
good i'm not the spy okay hold on
i'm definitely not this way
this is a nice location
all the locations are the same
they never checked no the locations yeah
the location reference never changes
by the way when you're a spy it'll show
you all the locations
and you can click on them to check them
off if you know it's not that you can
actually you can whittle it down a
little bit
based on everyone else's answers it's
very useful for keeping
keeping your head straight
nice so this one is definitely not pro
tip there nick the circus thanks man
i'm good it did me though because i
unchecked ocean liner so
[Laughter]
we can check ocean liner because there's
a lot of food based questions you have
the first question it looks like
oh i do what says you're disconnected
nick
oh oh oh after we have to uh let me just
refresh very good oh it was the other
one
awesome okay okay okay okay okay okay
um
[Music]
my role does not make sense um
oh i know she's not the spotlight
my role does not mix wait yeah maybe
she's just super high level
already i think she's very in round four
jake could be could be yeah
are you constantly moving
like what's like the flow of like
oh i suck at asking questions um what
are you moving
most of the time
am i am i moving most of the time as
like a
general existential are you moving in
are you moving towards a location most
of the time
that's all i'm gonna say take that
for what that is i'll say this um
depends which way it depends which way
the winds blow you know like i
don't sometimes
sometimes i'm moving sometimes i'm not
wow how crazy would it be if nick's the
spy again
oh yeah
no please would you like to raise your
hand
no would you like to ask me a question
first i'm gonna shut up it's not even my
turn
oh okay i'm not even a spy either
uh all right sam you say you're not the
spy but i
i'm gonna question that
um
oh man this is tough um
so you say you're not the spy huh kid
well if you say you're not the spy
then you'd be able to tell me how to get
off
of this thing
how do you get off of this thing how do
you get off yeah
just walk
walk away i mean
i mean that's that's how you get walk
away you walk away you get off that's
how you get off of it now as far as what
happens after that that's a whole other
story
but you'd have no concerns about what
would happen after that
well i'm not going to give you an
elaborate step-by-step of
the specifics with how i walk away
because any number of things could
happen
uh as you as you know
with this location but uh yeah it all
starts with
walking away either that or yes stay
right there
walk away or stay right there okay we're
getting now we're now we're really
honing in here
we're really drilling down i mean do you
want more i can
i can just keep talking about no it's
fine i don't think you should i don't
think you should
i i i agree i don't really i think i'm
done i think you should ask the next
question
yes nick yeah what's up man
um
how about
if you could pack your own lunch
knowing what you know about this
location yeah if you could pack your own
lunch go into this location
what's the one thing you would not
forget to pack
oh man well
you know i think a big bushel of oranges
would really suit me well
[Music]
for this location you know i think yeah
i don't want to be without my oranges
yeah perfect yeah moving on
i mean perfect moving on no no i get it
i get it
yeah yeah that's all i'll say i'm gonna
i'm not gonna ask my question
if if i would have picked a different
fruit but it's okay
sure thing that's that's your decision i
made mine
jordan yes
is there a clear system of hierarchy in
this location
actually no no please go on sorry i'll
leave it there
is there a clear system of hierarchy are
the rules defined
i would say yes okay yeah
would others say not yes
sam
[Laughter]
wouldn't be that i don't know i'm not
too sure about that
i don't know guys what i mean it was yes
or no question you know
sam hi tell me i'm here for
any answer you need what might you
be scared of
what might i be like what scared of
giving the location
given the location that we all know what
would you be most scared of
um
getting really sick
yeah dang i can't tell if it's sandra
jordan
that would be a shame nick what do you
think
i'm thinking jordan but also sam's
coming at me pretty hard
so sam's coming up with some pretty good
answers but i think he's just
trying to cast he's just bluffing with
coffin confidence
i think i know that's one of his tricks
it is one of my tricks but when i only
have 30 seconds
there's a specific reason and you i
think caught on to that
and i i mean i didn't answer jake's
question very well 20 seconds 20 seconds
wrap it up sam
all right jake i'll give you a good one
um um
no i'm putting it to a vote we have to
put it through a vote otherwise we lose
no no
okay jordan oh jordan
um sam oh sam
oh it's split all right well what
happens now
it's split jake i'm gonna ask you the
last question with the time we have
remaining
jake for my final question jake
the question is i'm going to name
three monsters and you pick the one
it's is it a godzilla
is it a devil or is it a mind flayer
there's one right answer it would have
to be godzilla
okay okay
[Laughter]
nevermind too obscure fine it's fine all
right well anyways i guess the spy
has i guess we it's like uh the spy kind
of wins slash has a chance to we'll
never know who the spy is
i'll never know we'll never know we'll
never know that does not sound like
jake's answer
i would have thought that he and i were
both we're calling it we have to figure
out who it is
look we have to know okay if you g if
we have to worry about my vote for
jordan sorry jordan
i'm still voting for jordan me too damn
don't flip a coin how could it be me i
was the spy before
that guys we ran out of time
i have a phone and it was it's it's it's
either jordan or sam
i'm not tis not me all right nick i'm
holding a number under my shirt
is it one or two it's two
though you guys vote for me
yes not the spy oh i'm not the spy
either oh god i knew it was nice it was
nick again
[Applause]
you were right sir
lightning strikes twice where is it
where are we pirate ship
yeah that's how i was able to give the
good answers
jake jake you were a little bit too uh
you're a bit too literal on your
first answer of sam's question i think
yeah the whole like sailing the seven
seas
i said it depends on which way the winds
blow i know
i know yeah but i was looking right at
pirate ship as you said
yeah that i know you weren't the spy um
i don't think the winds really affect
much of these other locations maybe the
circus town
airplane there's an airplane yeah
there's a day spa
congratulations on a successful spy
victory thank you thank you
thank you kind of done with that jake
you're welcome happy to help happy to
help all right we're hot dropping into a
brand new one
and uh i'm not the spy
again hey you need me so fortunate
screen cap
going we are you this one
i guess we already have it off the same
location
i won't tell anyone don't tell anyone
sam
but you do have the first question so
you do need to ask somebody
about this wonderful location that we're
at today
eight nick yeah sam uh
when you're at this location which way
do you definitely want the wind to blow
which way do i definitely want the wind
to blow man
that's a good question thanks look man
for me for me i'm just happy to feel any
wind at all you know what i mean i'm
just grateful for any wind
woohoo like i love all wind
yeah hell yeah brother
[Laughter]
sweet you love all wins that's an answer
right there
this guy's got answers and uh so
i'm not sure what you're doing right now
but it's exactly how i like to play the
spy or i'm like
like someone gives an answer and i like
each time i join in when people are like
good answer i'm like yeah great it's
pretty good
real good not to say you're the spy yet
i'm literally just joking
so jake yeah in terms of types of
exercise you like to do at this location
um do you like to a run lapse
b do push-ups which i know you like or
c uh somersaults
do you do something well it can be hard
to do exercise at this location
depending on
the time of day but i
personally you're asking me personally
push-ups yeah
all the time son okay okay yeah
okay i'm i
come on
that's jake you may ask your question
no no come on let's hear jake's question
here i think it'll be very illuminating
what else would you want
have wanted me to say there oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah moving on moving on
what what else no no jake we'll get to
what else no one's making any
accusations oh we'll get to the what
else we'll i'll ask you a great question
later
okay unless no your question's very bad
i'll be asking the questions i was asked
a question i'll be asking the questions
all right um
if the wind was blowing
at you uh-huh
who are you i'm asking
[Laughter]
if the wind was blowing at you wait did
jordan just ask me a question no
no no no no no no it's nick okay yeah
yeah if the wind was blowing at you
it's jake no it is not
come on
if the wind is blowing at you would you
be going down
oh my god
down yeah so i just answer that
you know what man i'm just happy to be
failing any air at all
[Laughter]
you didn't believe me and then we get
that answer all right okay
thank you can we no further questions
your honor
can i put something into a vote well
this is a spy vote
a spy vote it's so obvious yeah i agree
it's jake
about jake jordan did you hear the
answer jordan i'm not ready to vote
you hold on jordan you have not
exonerated yourself
ask a question please declare your name
all she says is i'd be happy to feel it
any wind at all
i know so the promise that jake you had
two in my opinion
two stand by that answer your honor
pretty waffly answers
and questions and then jordan just
literally repeated
nick's answer okay okay okay how many
questions can you let me ask you pick
between two foods sam
spam or a pokeball
spam okay i'll vote for jake yeah
wait it's jake well it doesn't matter
because i know you guys
that because you guys are on the
military base no
oh come on yeah almost though you're
very close it's close
it's a mobile military base it's yeah it
stops up my ring
come on because you heard spam though
spam yeah so you thought that was a good
question to exonerate yourself you did
that question yeah
and the thing is like those those like
clutch last second questions that are
like
we're like oh like see jake picked up on
that too it's like we got to get that
boat out
question how can you start off the
question what way is the wind blowing
there's no wind that's how you yeah
that's the only one in this whole thing
where there's no wind and
half the questions were wind related i
just
kicked it off with your question it's
like kind of a joke it was like a little
freaking job
it was a backwards question a negative
yeah the old backwards
questions all right well let's hit up
one more guys
um i'm not the spy once again
i've got a really good track record sam
is
almost certainly the spy this time he
hasn't been
at all yes but yep it's totally likely
just as likely well not just as likely
completely fair to assume that i'm not
tell us more about how you're not the
spy it's okay well i'll tell you once
i'm asked
once i'm asked a question okay bye well
sam i have the first question i have the
honor
of the first question so let me ask you
a very
specific question about this place and
it's going to sound a little ambiguous
but if you know the location you'll give
me the right answer he's a cake
circles or squares circles are squares
that's circles duh
yeah okay i'm gonna ask you a question
yeah yeah shoot
um
[Music]
nuclear fusion or coal
oh you know what as much as people tout
nuclear i'm i'm a cold guy myself i've
always believed in it
my father before me was a cold guy
really yeah
i i i think it's the way to go cold big
coal big
coal big coal oh yeah
i don't know man that's um
okay you don't know you don't know you
don't you don't know
it's it's not it's not what's never i
won't say anymore
i don't want to okay yeah yeah for sure
okay
so jake
um let's see here
sorry i'm just trying to think of a
question that'll prove you're the spy um
oh good luck good luck
i know it's tough to think of questions
when yeah when you're the spied
yeah it is it's really i'm going to ask
you to i'm going to ask you guys guys
hold on hold on hold on we've answered
great questions
it's been fine we don't have the spite
so
jake yeah at this location
do you bring your own alcohol or do you
go to a designated place
uh well
you're supposed to go to a place but
that doesn't doesn't always work out
like that
um okay great
approved approved
not mad at that all right um
jordan what's it oh
i'm gonna ask a question from an earlier
round is there a
established sense of um roles
is there a hierarchy at this location
or is it just kind of like you know
people doing their thing
there's some people doing their thing
yeah and
some people that are guiding people who
are doing anything
some people that are doing their thing
[Laughter]
really have to know what they're doing
or else things could go wrong
i'm done cool
so it definitely could go wrong if
somebody doesn't know what they're doing
it could definitely go wrong this whole
restaurant could just start on fire
this whole crusade could just go up and
snow this whole cruise
we walked the wrong way this is one
flaming corporate party
there's no shrimp at the party boy
all right jordan sorry to distract from
your question here
that was it that was me sorry sorry
sorry sorry
i'm sorry
all right three minutes left okay jake
minutes let's go would you say you're
more of like uh well you can't ask me i
already okay okay okay
okay yeah yeah nick
yeah would you say you would feel more
comfortable
[Music]
near the water or near land
um you know
for me it doesn't really matter what i'm
near
it just matters
if everyone's supposed to be there or
not
[Music]
yep
god i wish i could throw you back a
question right now
are you ready to vote yeah i'm ready
okay um
who are we voting for jordan jordan
jordan oh
very interesting it's not
no that's because it's me
that's because it's nice
and we're on the submarine i thought you
were gonna like
and we're getting hit and we're on the
submarine oh no we're not on this one
mr moneybags
oh man well good questions though cause
i'm
i was i was misled so
good i started
the way he answered that i'm i would be
more comfortable in land on a treaty
train that's just me
but you said bye by the water yeah i was
imagining a
train going over like a beautiful bridge
i wouldn't be comfortable there yeah
i mean hey my job is the border patrol
for some reason on a train i don't know
why
there's a boat
make sure everyone's supposed to be
there yeah i was the train driver
all right so you have to make sure
things don't go wrong
i promise never to accuse anyone of
being a spy again
you're um everyone's just doing their
thing lying
screwed me up because yeah i thought we
were on the submarine and then you said
that
and i was like oh maybe yeah i was like
i was like
this could be anywhere i mean people are
just doing their thing
and it's like casino baseball
it was so big that it didn't make me
yeah
they were just doing their thing just
doing it it was so vague that it did
mislead me but now it makes sense
it does on the train people are
literally chilling yeah that's true
screen cap final round the final round
and once again for final round not the
spy
this is a winner take all scenario it
doesn't matter what's happened up to
this point
if the spy wins then they win if the
non-spies win
then they win the whole game the whole
game the whole and even if you were a
spy
earlier and you lost doesn't matter it
doesn't matter yeah
yeah okay all right
at some point in this game i'm gonna
tell the audience if i'm the spy or not
so you guys can you know keep an eye out
for it
i'm just saying i'm not the spy i'm just
gonna say real quick i'll give you two
sound bites i'm not the spy and then
also give you
i'm the spy i may or may not but you can
use whichever one and it ends up being
i'm gonna go with jake is this
so all right that's a minute of the game
has been that's been used yeah sorry all
right all right
first question right there jordan since
you're so convinced
since you're so convinced um uh
i wonder you at this location at this
location do you prefer
water or ice
i definitely would like some ice hmm
definitely that's it okay cool
all right
i'm gonna turn the tables on this whole
thing real quick yes
because i already know what's going on
at this stage
i already know what's going on in this
game just letting y'all know
mm-hmm yeah burning time
sam i'm not saying
yes canned soda
or water in a glass canned soda or water
in the glass
hmm well i'm feeling like can soda right
now
classic but that's just because i don't
quite understand the question so i'm
just picking that
because it feels like the type of thing
i'd do
okay that is like you picked ice i got
canned soda great combo
soda in the glass of ice put them
together and you guys
got a great thing going yeah nick yeah
what's up man
nick yes sam um
[Music]
what's one power tool you would not want
to forget
is it your circular saw
or your power drill oh i'm glad you
asked that because
yesterday i thought i forgot my power
drill and
i almost had a heart attack so
definitely the power drill cool
yeah yeah
wow these are okay let's get more
specific i haven't gained anything from
anybody i thought i knew the table
i don't know the table anymore you got
somebody some good questions ask some
nick please ask something something
okay specific okay okay okay anything
let's get party
no not anything exactly the opposite of
anything
what would you never
forget to pack on this journey okay i'm
talking
flats a is flats b
a down jacket c
sunglasses
on a few things on that list i will ask
you when you say
flats yeah like like some like sandals
slip them on easy don't think about it
you know
just want to make sure yeah i would like
i
really want some sunglasses they really
do
but then and you're saying like you
would never want to forget that the
sunglasses
yeah is that your final yeah yeah is
that your final answer
it's the final it is all right
let's move on all right i don't know
i don't know it's either sam or jordan
that's my
sunglasses i mean
you're probably you know why because
there is actually a thing to that
yeah there is you know what i'm saying
that's the trick one
yeah so jordan i mean
it's your turn to ask a question uh
unless
unless you want to raise that hand sam
no not yet i'm not
yeah i'm not i'm taking my time i got
three minutes
we got three whole minutes to figure
this out
jake that's me that's the name they gave
me
why would you not want to uh
why would you want sunglasses
are you asking so that i tell you the
location
or are you asking me so that i
reveal to you that i am indeed not the
spy take this however you want
hey she's asking the questions around
here mister oh you're right sorry
i can't ask a question to a question
uh what sorry what was
what would you use the sunglasses for
yeah why would you want these sunglasses
why would you want them well it's it's
sunny at this location that's why you
would want them it
can be very sunny mm-hmm
yeah yeah yeah yeah
true true yeah it's true yeah i just
wanted to know
yeah okay let me make sure that i got
one more for sam
and then i think we can wrap this up all
right we'll close we can close the books
on this one after this question we can
close the books
because i'm pretty sure it's sam that's
why i need sam
okay see this is another one of those
split ones that you're
gonna get messy jake
bring it come on come on bring it in
bring it in that's good sam
sam yeah there are there are bears
at this location okay and i need you to
tell me of the three bears
tell me a bear that is not
at this location i'm going to give you
three bears okay okay
grizzly grizzly bear
black bear polar bear polar bears
polar bears are not at this location
polar ice
did you hear me jake yeah i said
polar bears yes
okay i'm looking around do i see any
polar bears
nope
[Laughter]
all right hell no if i saw a polar bear
here i would freak
i feel like an episode of lost i'd be
like what the hell is a polar bear doing
here
that's what i'd say your honor i believe
we can cast our votes
i'm saying that right now that's my
final answer
are you proposing a vote nick oh i'm
proposing it sam all the way
after that hold on no hold on but no
hold on i'm proposing i'm proposing that
it's jordan
how why do the tables turn like that
because
i know that's why i swear like i mean
wait maybe he is maybe look you asked me
that [ __ ] question you serious like
if i answer it i'm
giving it away yeah i said give me a
bear that is not at that location
i know you know and if i
look you're putting them in a tough spot
you put me in a tough little
it's not a tough spot just give me a
bear that's you put me in a little cubby
hole
jake he already answered two of the
bears aren't there
the thing is the sarcasm doesn't like
work
remotely as well as this because i can
turn the neck and i can wink at him see
hey nick
i can see your wink i see your wing can
i okay you saw it good
i see your wig can i raise you a vote
that it's jordan all right
okay the sunglasses thing yeah uh it's
yeah all right so we voted for you again
i'm sorry it was you that's fine
because i am this yeah exactly i'm the
spy
thank you for linking dude
why did you
gosh dang it maybe it was too obvious
why didn't you just casually say like
black bear because i wanted to say
i wanted to sarcastically say the wrong
answer yeah but you
you drove it so hard that she figured it
out
jordan i she's a trick how did you
figure it out i think you're smart
enough to know that when i don't say
polar bears
you're like so there's polar bears here
i was a little confused you know i
picked up on everyone's
i had the right they were going i think
you you i think you were in
because you're like polar bears
supermarket yeah hotel
movie studio maybe there's no zoo here
i was i was either looking for the
jungle or for like an ice place
you said ice you asked me a bunch of you
said flop circus tent
jackie circus now i mean like maybe like
an icelandic circus
there could be a polar bear in a world
war ii squad
okay oh you're right in siberia yeah
it's like
there could be a polar bear at a movie
studio there could be a polar bear at a
military base
look look look look the plus out of this
is that there could be a polar bear out
of this
non spice formed at a restaurant
all i know is i won't at a police
station jordan won
jordan a passenger train and that's it
all the games that came before don't
matter
espionage espionage all right
jordan jordan congratulations all of the
games of spyfall
very shortly i hope that you guys
enjoyed this episode it was a little
different
uh let us know if you liked it in the
comments um because we can certainly
play more of this or we can play other
games
i was actually thinking we could play
monopoly and just
or checkers team checkers we'll just put
the mic next to the pieces
two two people on each team team
checkers
oh you know it'd be a fun one for a
podcast boulder dash might be a little
bit
long but that could be fun
i don't know if you've ever played it
i've never played i heard it's fun
yeah it's a pretty fun game it's it's
pretty fun it's it's also a bluffing
game
so you know quite like this
sweet seems like we enjoy it one more
thing we
we just dropped a new version of the
android app for cordon digital.com
oh yeah it's beautiful and it's
brilliant and
huge thanks to scott and his team for
putting it together so uh if you're
subscribed to the website definitely go
ahead and download that if you're on
android
and ios is coming in a few more weeks
because we had to reprogram a whole
playlist because the one we were using
was janky
so anyways you know would be a really
cool feature of that app in the future
a corridor spyfall custom game
like custom locations yeah big bear
studios
podcast room yeah studio floor
that's sweet it could be pretty easy to
make right says the guy who doesn't know
any coding
yeah we could do that yeah yeah yeah we
could make that
accordingly right now
[Music]
bears are not always in the polar
station
[Music]
sometimes there's grizzly
bears there sometimes
unlikely definitely not black bears
definitely
not polar bears
[Music]
thanks for listening everybody have a
great day
bye bye bye